I've heard tales of your kind which
you're a mutant
created by magic roaming the continent
we don't want your kind here hunting
monsters for a price I thought you'd
have found or horns or something
I had them filed down
people call you a monster too
why not them because that I am what
they say I have all of our choices draw
our destinies closer
he's out there there's still hope
I have to find Geralt of Rivia
judge me they say witches can't feel
human emotion what do you believe in
greater
and it's all the same
princess cirilla
the old destiny
I can't protect her
if you dismiss it
unleash
a true calamity upon us all
I'll take that chance
welcome back everyone its charlie we
finally have the full official trailer
for The Witcher so we'll break it down
there's a whole bunch of book stuff
going on during this a lot of Easter
eggs if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I will be doing videos for the series
when it drops they finally confirmed the
official release date it's pretty much
exactly when we all thought it was going
to happen the week before Christmas so
we will be talking about all kinds of
Witcher stuff at the end of the year if
you're not familiar with the series or
you haven't read the books or played the
games don't worry but the games are
amazing the books are actually what the
series is going to cover the games are
meant to be a sequel story that pick up
after the events of the books but
starting with the footage the voiceover
you get at the beginning of the trailer
is yennefer talking to him talking about
I've heard about witchers I've heard
about all these mutations and the
potions that you take that's all
happening during this banquet scene
where all the different people are
trying to screw each other in the
background it's not the sorcerer's
banquet from time of contempt that's one
of the later books season 1 is only
covering the short stories from the
first two books the last wish and sword
of Destiny this trailer is meant to be
the basic explainer for who Geralt of
Rivia is why he acts the way he does
what wishers do what his general
philosophy is like this later woman says
why don't you just all those
terrible people - he says because that
would make me the monster that they say
I am part of his code is that he only
monsters when they're a danger to
other people all these dead bodies at
the beginning of the trailer seem like
they're from the fall of Cintra later
after nilfgaard comes back to invade on
the orders of Emperor Amir we'll be
talking about him a lot during the
series he's not the main villain but he
comes pretty close to being one of the
bigger villains then they do this thing
where they juxtaposed Yenefer's purple
eyes with Geralt see yellow cat eyes as
he's getting though Witcher potions and
undergoing his Witcher mutations that
grant him his special powers and long
lifespan yennefer also goes through some
transformations physical transformations
when she attains her power is a
sorceress this scene of Geralt during
the day walking into this fight seems
like it's from butcher of lavich and it
might seem like there are a ton of
different fights and battles going on in
the trailer but really it's just
different scenes from the same three to
four fights broken up into a bunch of
different parts this battle when he's
fighting the soldiers
seems like it's Winnie's helping Dooney
in pavetta earlier in the story Geralt
is brought to Cintra by Ciri's
grandmother Queen Calanthe to oversee
the wedding of her daughter Ciris mother
pavetta : 'they has all these suitors
and nobles from neighboring kingdoms
that's what these banquet scenes or four
but pavetta is really in love with a
cursed monster are cursed human that
looks like a monster named Unni he's the
one that looks like he has the head of a
hedgehog no spoilers for dooney's secret
identity we'll talk about that later
after the series premieres there's a
whole lot going on here that we can't
really talk about without getting into
spoilers but all the trailers talk about
people being worse than monsters the
wedding here is an example of Queen kal
anthe in the people of central and the
nobles being terrible people in karma is
a bitch
because after Geralt manages to save
Dooney and prevent pavetta from being
forced to marry one of these other
suitors you see later in time nilfgaard
sacks Cintra and Queen Calanthe lays dying
yelling it's ciri to go seek out Geralt
for protection they're just an example
of karma coming back around on terrible
people like is it's terrible that
nilfgaard is invading and sacking Cintra
but they themselves were just as
terrible to duny in pavetta earlier in
the story we can't go too deep on why
nilfgaard is invading without getting
into spoilers so we'll talk about that
when the series premieres but really
they're after ciri and Nilfgard is
trying to consolidate power by
conquering all the neighboring kingdoms
so ciri is not the only thing that
they're after this is the school where
yennefer studied to be a sorceress then
there's the scene of her trying to make
it with Geralt at this banquet Geralt
riding into bladvic in taking the
witcher potions as the ennifer talks
about the story she's heard of witchers
and the mutations that they undergo we
get our first look at Jaskier with
Geralt and Roach riding down the road
this might be from the last wish the
last wish is really the first time the
geralt and yennefer meet but they may
change that a little bit for the books
the way she's talking to him here makes
it seem like it's the first time that
they've met but really it's earlier in
the story when they actually meet for
the first time so it's kind of hard to
tell based on the way they cut this
footage this is more of Geralt getting
ready to fight off Renfri's men in
Blaviken this scene of the people in
the tavern treating him like crap is
just another example of how normal
people are generally mistrustful and
fearful of all
it's not just Geralt that they're afraid
of they just opposed this with Geralt
fighting monsters who kind of seemed
terrible then notice how they jump back
and forth between that and then the
scenes of regular people being even more
terrible in Blaviken in the tavern
like the monsters seemed bad but it's
really humans who are Terribad these
are scenes of him actually fighting Ren
free herself I did a whole video
explaining the meaning behind the name
Geralt is given the butcher of bladvic
and I'll link that at the end of this
but the super-quick version is that ren
free is coming to bladvic in to get
revenge against a sorcerer called Stregobor who himself is a very terrible
person and who she has a lot of history
with and good reason to want to get
revenge against him but in order to do
that she threatens the lives of all
these normal townspeople who aren't
doing anything in bladvic and so Geralt
is forced to all of Renfri's men
to protect those townspeople but at the
end of it it gets even worse for him
because he fights all these people off
saves the townspeople but the
townspeople themselves treat him like a
monster because he looks like he just
butchered get it butcher oblivion all
these people so they started throwing
rocks at him so even the people that he
just saved from being or
acting horribly towards him
this giant battle scene just seems like
it's one of the major nilfgaardian wars
with Cintra maybe the Battle of sodden
hill they're really two major Wars with
nilfgaard and Cintra so this could be
either one this is yennefer and Geralt
on the road it might be during the last
wish earlier during their first beating
from the books but like I said it's kind
of hard to tell how much they've changed
the timeline of the books this is just
kalantay dying telling ciri to find
Geralt because he'll protect her from
the nilfgaardian 'he's this scene of
Geralt on the castle bridge might be
from earlier at the beginning of pavetta
sweating
this is ciri in the middle of her escape
from Cintra there was a longer version
of this scene that they screened last
week at London Comic Con where she runs
into a boy and they sort of give you
some scenes with her that let you know
what her personality is like before she
winds up in the force too Brokilon
with the dryads but then she's actually
in Brokilon
talking to the dryads it's probably
right before she meets Geralt for the
first time then they have a whole bunch
of scenes from pavetta 's wedding when
all breaks loose and Geralt tries
to save Duny from being by
everyone else they the funny scene of
him talking to Roach don't judge me
horse he calls all of his horses Roach
he goes through several different horses
but they might just give him the one
brooch during season one this is just an
example of nilfgaardian soldiers being
terrible just to sell you on the idea
that they're coming for ciri like I said
there's no real main villain in The
Witcher series it just some people are
more terrible than others at times
there's a bunch of different scenes of
Ciri escaping from Cintra and vesemir
trying to compel Geralt to save her
talking about destiny terrible things
will happen if you don't as they show
all these cataclysms and invasions in
the background ciri being his destiny so
to speak has made clear to him in wait
for it a book called sword of Destiny
see how they did that the scene of ciri
using her power just meant to show you
how special she is and explain a little
bit about her elder blood they might not
get too deep into that during the
beginning of the series this scene of
the ground cracking in and around Cintra
could be coming from Vilgefortz or another
sorcerer there are a lot of sorcerers in
The Witcher series and most of them are
terrible people
but Vilgefortz is the closest thing
to a main villain as you could say that
the series has but he's working with
nilfgaard and Emperor Emhyr when they
start to try and conquer all the
neighboring kingdoms then you get that
last voiceover from Geralt explaining
his philosophy evil is evil greater
lesser evil it's all the same
this here is Fringilla next to the
trebuchet during the invasion of Cintra
she's just another nilfgaardian
sorceress from the series
this is yennefer in a different court
after she gets her powers and becomes a
sorceress she serves in a number of
different kingdoms before she meets
Geralt for the first time more of ciri
on the run more of Geralt fighting a
different band of marauders vesemir
still yelling at Geralt chasing him down
talking about destiny to help ciri this
person before we've seen it a lot of the
trailers is to saya she's one of the
people that takes in yennefer when she's
younger and trains her to become a
sorceress then there's a whole bunch of
footage from the comic-con scenes that
they showed up last week with yennefer
and queen Kahless of Leiria trying to
save her from an unknown sorcerer to
this trying to her in her baby
then this scene is more footage from the
end of the last trailer scene of Geralt
fighting that giant spider monster in
the swamps while he's all potion'd up the
spider monster is actually called a
Kikomore they show up all over the
Witcher games there's a bunch of them
that live in swamps they have very human
looking heads but everybody let me know
in the comments if you spotted any
Easter eggs or anything big in the
trailer that I didn't mention
in the video when the series gets here
I'll find some cool Witcher themed
giveaway to do for all my videos so
leave all your suggestions in the
comments below but like I said they'll
probably be a couple more promos and
trailers that they'll drop before
premieres in December while you wait for
everything click here for my breakdown
of those other big Comic Con scenes and
learn why Geralt is called the butcher
of Blaviken and click here for the
teaser for the brand-new Game of Thrones
prequel that they just announced House
of the Dragon about the Targaryen family
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight!